it's time for people who know they're in
a sketch
versus people who don't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this is quickly becoming one of my
favorite shows of all time are you ready
i am definitely ready me
too
and please sit back and enjoy people who
know they're in a sketch
versus people who don't
[Music]
all right well uh tonight uh conan conan
actually i'm sorry to interrupt but your
test results have just come back from
the lab
oh gee doctor can't it wait i mean it's
it's kind of personal
well dr wilson and i kind of think you
should know now
right dr wilson
hold on that's not doctor that is my
wife
hello betty i haven't seen you in years
since you left me for that
jockey
hello hank yeah me and your wife
it didn't work out i've been with uh
bill here for the past six months
yeah that's right we'll try it bill
i'll tell you something bill bill here
really knows how to make a guy feel
appreciated
easy bill yeah he's not he's much better
than lou
my old boyfriend hello lou
just one second is that the lou i think
it is
lou daniels
say lou how's the canadian hydroponic
marijuana smuggling ring going
i see well perhaps your partner
billy the bong bolatino could shed some
more light on this
whoa whoa whoa i don't know what you're
talking about it's the doctors that
smuggled the weed
well then i suppose the dingle twins are
off the hook
well it looks like this mystery's all
wrapped up
hey jerry
and doctor i guess i will take those
results now what are they
well i'm sorry conan the test came back
positive positive that you have
absolutely nothing so you have
absolutely nothing and i'm positive
or does he
that was people who know they're in a
sketch versus people who don't